Reactome has another tool called ReactomeGSA
which allows users to analyse proteomics,
transcriptomics and microarray data.
Datasets from all of these methods can be
combined in a single analysis.
Thereby, ReactomeGSA can perform multi-omics
pathway analyses.
Its main feature is that it performs quantitative
pathway analyses, the so called “gene set
analyses”.
This increases the statistical power of the
differential expression analysis, which is
directly performed on the pathway level.
ReactomeGSA is integrated into Reactome’s
data analysis tool suite in the Analyze Data
interface.
The input file must be a tab-delimited text
file, such as CSV or TSV file, where the first
column contains the gene or protein identifiers
and all subsequent columns the respective
samples.
The first row contains the sample names and
all subsequent rows the genes or proteins.
In the first screen, you need to select the
algorithm to use for the differential pathway
analysis.
The detailed parameters for each algorithm
can be adapted by clicking the blue icon on
the left of the algorithm’s box.
PADOG and Camera perform a differential expression
analysis between two groups of samples.
ssGSEA is a so-called gene set variation approach
that returns pathway-level quantitative data
for each sample.
PADOG stands for Pathway Analysis with Down-weighting
of Overlapping Genes computes a gene set score
based on gene weights that are designed to
emphasize the genes appearing in few gene
sets, versus genes that appear in many gene
sets.
Inter-gene correlations can skew analysis
results.
Camera or Correlation Adjusted MEan RAnk gene
set test is based on the idea of estimating
the inter-gene correlation from the data,
and using it to adjust the gene set test statistic.
Single-sample GSEA or ssGSEA calculates separate
enrichment scores for each pairing of a sample
and gene set.
Each ssGSEA enrichment score represents the
degree to which the genes in a particular
gene set are coordinately up- or down-regulated
within a sample.
After clicking “Continue”, you are presented
with the now empty list of datasets.
Click the “+ Add dataset” button to add
a new dataset.
Now, you have to select the type of dataset
you want to load.
To upload your own data, select one of the
options under “Select a file from a local
folder”.
To test the tool, it is possible to quickly
load example data.
Currently, ReactomeGSA provides three example
datasets, two matched datasets on melanoma
associated B cells and one scRNA-seq dataset
on B cells.
Finally, it is possible to directly load datasets
from ExpressionAtlas.
To do so, first navigate to ExpressionAtlas
in a separate tab or window.
Once a dataset is added, you need to annotate
the experimental metadata.
This is necessary in order to define the groups
for the differential expression analysis in
the next step.
You can adapt the dataset’s name in the
“Dataset name” box at the top.
This name will be used for all results.
To increase the readability, we suggest to
use as short names as possible.
To add an annotation, click the “plus”
symbol on the right.
This will add a new empty column to the table.
First, add a heading to define the name of
the property, for example, “treatment”.
Next, add the values for every sample that
you want to include in your comparisons.
Samples without any values will simply be
ignored.
In the final step of adding a dataset, you
have to define which groups to compare.
The “comparison factor” drop-down menu
contains all parameters that were annotated
in the sample table before.
“1st group” and “2nd group” define
which groups of samples to compare against
each other.
Depending on which “comparison factor”
you select, the available values for the “1st
group” and “2nd group” will change automatically.
Additionally, some gene set analysis methods
allow you to define so-called “covariates”.
These are parameters that might cause a bias
in your result that you would like to correct
for.
Simply select the relevant ones for your experiment.
Once you click “Continue” you will be
returned to the list of datasets where you
will now see your annotated dataset in the
list.
If you want, you can add any number of datasets
to a single request.
Once you click “Continue” from the dataset
list view, the final analysis options are
shown.
“Create REACTOME visualizations” is always
selected.
If it is de-selected, the result cannot be
visualised in Reactome’s pathway browser.
This option is generally only relevant to
users of the ReactomeGSA R package.
If you select “Create reports”, ReactomeGSA
will automatically create a Microsoft Excel
and PDF report of your results.
Additionally, it will create a short R script
that allows you to load your data directly
into an R session.
In case you provide your email address, you
are automatically notified as soon as the
analysis is complete.
The mail will contain direct links to the
generated reports and a link to the visualisation
in the PathwayBrowser.
Launch the analysis by clicking the “GO”
button.
If you provided an email address, you can
also close your browser.
The analysis will still continue on our servers
and you will be notified as soon as it is
done.
Some analysis with many large datasets, for
example comparing five TCGA datasets in a
single analysis, may require up to an hour
to complete.
ReactomeGSA analysis calculates up and down
regulation of genes or proteins based on the
submitted dataset.
Results of this analysis are presented similar
to that of over-representation with a few
additional elements that are described below:
• Up and down regulation of genes or proteins
are indicated as arrow heads pointing up or
down respectively.
If the value is significant, there are two
arrow heads.
• The Analysis tab in the Details panel
contains an additional column indicating if
the pathway is up or down regulated, which
corresponds to the average value of all the
genes or proteins of that pathway.
• The colour scale in the diagram panel
that indicates the expression value of genes/proteins
is divided into five categories.
o Significantly up-regulated
o Non-significantly up-regulated
o Not found
o Non-significantly down-regulated
o Significantly down-regulated